Thank You Steven okay so thanks
everybody and thanks for the invitation
it's been a pleasure being here so far
so today I'm gonna talk to you a little
bit about a project that we've been
working on for about a year and a half
now and creating a market space for data
and providing an algorithmic approach
this is work with our students Aneesh
Agarwal to him Sarkar and their Racha
this is going to be a slice of the work
that we're doing is just hard to talk
about everything we're doing in half an
hour so let me just sort of motivate the
work and maybe give you some idea about
some of the challenges and how we
resolve some of the challenges for
creating such a marketplace you know so
the data has become a currency in the
digital market almost every corporation
right now is thinking about utilizing
either their own data or buying data in
order to predict certain things or
improve their value proposition or their
business model and so forth in fact some
companies have completely changed their
business model into a data-driven
business model and so this thing in
common really and really by the day very
important and in fact this Court is kind
of interesting and says that personal
data is the new oil of the internet and
the new currency of the digital world
okay fit so from our perspective it's a
currency then how do you value it okay
and it seems like there's a lot of
interesting challenges that face not
just individuals like us when we are
asked to sort of provide our data for a
value also even big companies like
Bloomberg Reuters Nielsen these
companies engage sort of long-term
contracts with their customers they're
often it's not the case that they would
actually figure out how much value the
data that they sold their customer is
and in fact they're having a very hard
time convincing other people to buy
their data because it's not clear how
the data is gonna be valuable to them
and everyone is going around talking
about so how much value this data set is
and if you talk to Reuters I mean they
have these pricing methods of data sets
over certain periods of time and
doesn't seem to make a lot of sense in
fact actually even from an individual
point of view and there's another issue
there is that if you for example give
your data to 23andme
you pay $100 to give your data and for
in return you get a service and the
services that they tell you okay where
you came from and some some extraction
of of the projection of your genome on
on different parts of the world however
what you don't know is that right now
they own your data and potentially this
data we don't know what's happening this
data could be sold to insurance
companies so maybe we discover something
wrong with the genomic that you have and
then your insurance would get jacked up
so now all of a sudden the service you
got is much much more expensive than
$100 that you paid and I think this is
happening in credit reports it's
happening to us everywhere a privacy
issue obviously is is that the crux of
all of this but we know that we have no
privacy and in fact I think it's
becoming even more complicated in
looking at breaches like the Equifax
situation 150 million people lost their
data or their data became public
financial data social data and so forth
and it's not clear that we know exactly
how to value that breach I mean it's
certainly kind of overwhelming to know
that so much data has been so but how
much value how much does it matter if my
data is available to some random person
out there how much can they do with it
I'm not really sure myself how to value
that certainly there are sort of the
whole thing that happened with Cambridge
analytical which is not a breach that
was a sales that Facebook has done to
Cambridge analytical everybody is sort
of appalled actually did even Facebook
get the right value from Cambridge
analytical on the data that this also
this is all these questions are really
interesting and so it kind of calls for
creating a market for data to understand
how to value it and how to exchange it
it's a real-time market because things
are changing very very rapidly and
almost the history matter is very little
in these kind of situations but there
are challenges to creating a market for
data ok and one and some of these
challenges I listed over here one
is their application at zero marginal
cost if you have a data point you can
sell that one bit a point but you can
also sell multiple copies of that data
point and it doesn't cost you anything
to sell multiple copies its value may
increase or decrease depending on the
vendors that are buying the data from
you we don't know that upfront how many
copies of the data you are to be selling
the second thing is that the value of
the data to affirm in is inherently
combinatorial that is if I have multiple
features or data sets and I'm interested
in a particular prediction task maybe
different combinations of these data
sets will contribute better to my to my
prediction and so you have to try out
all of these different combinations in
any whatever market that you create of
course I mean the prediction tasks that
companies have very widely I mean
different companies have and I'll give
you some examples in a second one aspect
is that the authenticity and the value
of data cannot be determined a priori
you almost have to do it take the data
try it out see if it adds value to you
and then price it okay because in
general you don't know ahead of time
what the value of the data is this is
not the stock market where you have some
prediction of what's going on and
finally I would say that also there is a
value there's an issue of externality
because if a data point goes to my
competitor then it actually matters to
me okay and so it's not just whether I
get the data but also if the data goes
to the competitor it actually changes my
my cost function okay and so okay so
just quickly here I don't want to spend
too much time comparing this you can
actually go through the nitty details of
comparing creating a data market a data
market to auction markets or stock
markets or even prediction markets and
you'll see that some of these challenges
are not present in this existing market
some are and some are not but for
example in the ad in stock markets you
know you simply cannot replicate the ad
there's a physical space that you sell
there's a physical stock if you start
replicating you devalue and there is
also an issue about the history of
being relevant to the pricing of a
particular product and finally I think
the way you educate these things depend
on simply on their bid if you bid higher
than the price you get their education
if you pay more than the price or their
the price of the stock you buy the stock
and the diction markets have similar
sort of simplicity's to them ok so I
want to get into talking about creating
a robust matching market for data and
describe it to you in pieces and tell
you how we sort of address some of the
challenges ok so so what is the market
what is this market it has sellers that
come in the sellers have datasets that
they would like to sell ok thank you
miss feature Thingiverse data sets fix
our t vector ok buyers come to the
market and the buyers have both a
prediction task they're interested in
predicting something as well as they
have a way to value the accuracy on this
prediction so a good example to think
about is that the buyers are retailers
they're trying to predict a demand on a
particular product at a particular time
ok
the accuracy in this prediction
translates directly to the cost and they
know that if you give me better accuracy
on this particular cause this is the
amount of dollars they actually save so
this valuation is something that they
know up front ok and they're interested
in this demand question right and so
maybe they're buying data from you know
from individual people or from Twitter
or sentiments or from you know kind of
Finance trying to figure out how the
economy inflation rates are they buying
data from every everywhere trying to
predict this particular task ok now the
markets task is to take the data that's
available and assign it or allocate it
to the buyers of course after they do
that they have to extract a certain
payment from the buyers and take that
payment and distributed to their sellers
and that distribution has to be also
fair because different sellers their
data was more valuable than others ok
one thing that is important in this
particular market to think about and the
example I gave you may be in retail is a
good
sort of running example for this is that
the market has to agree on how we
evaluate the accuracy of prediction so
that's something that is agreed upon in
addition actually we have to agree on
how we do the prediction so what is the
inference algorithm pretty machine
learning algorithm whatever we use that
is already fixed and agreed upon by
everybody of how to evaluate this right
so that we we take that out of the
formula right now okay and the two of
these two okay so one other point I want
to make is that of course there's many
different levels of this that you can
make this problem complicated you can
have sellers coming in in real time
buyers coming in real-time and matching
happening all the time right now what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna fix one side
of this and I'm gonna say that the
sellers are fixed I will have M of these
sellers buyers are coming one at a time
in real time and this allocation is
happening so a buyer is buying the set
and then they leave and then they buy
another set and so forth right you can
have the flip side of this problem and
also you can have the general problem
that will take a lot more time to
describe and we don't have all the
results for all of these complications
okay all right so the application of the
two-sided market this also has different
application I've talked a little bit
about the retail application of course
this could be in transportation where
somebody so for example municipality is
interested in estimating the utilization
of infrastructure congestion of some
sort right and and so they would like to
collect data from uber from lifts from
buses from taxis and whatever right and
they want to run this real-time
prediction so how do they do that how
are they what's the value of the data
and how they price it so that's one part
another example which actually got us
really interested in this is trying to
understand how all of this affects the
real-time demand response in a power in
an extra city market and that's another
place where you're thinking about the
data of people in their utilization for
example of their vehicles or electric
vehicles or in potentially having their
own renewables you know how is that
they're helpful to some sort of an
aggregator or aggregators that then will
able to mitigate some uncertainty with
the grid so how do you do that
particular pricing I the market okay so
let me describe the problem so the
seller is as I said there would be M
sellers fixed in the problem each have
data set X sub J vector from 0 to t ok
buyers come in the system yn at every
time and for some time and as I said the
buyers have a prediction task or
describe that as a vector y n could be
the demand for example in the retail
example mu n is their valuation of a
unit gain of accuracy so this is how
much money they are willing to pay for
getting a certain unit gain of accuracy
and BN is their bid okay which I haven't
described yet but that is all right so
what happens in this market and you know
in quickly run through this real-time
market how it's gonna work and then tell
you what the challenges are and then if
I have time I'll tell you how to solve
them okay so the first thing is the
real-time time n right or time T the
market has priced the individual data
sets so it has a P vector that prices
these data sets the buyers come in and
they build and based on the bid and the
price they allocate data sets to the
individual people okay and then they
evaluate the gain in accuracy and then
they determine the price okay the
payment that these people have to pay
and then they advocate
so when you say that's missing here no
so in this model that I said it said
that the buyers are coming one at a time
so it doesn't have that particular
problem right because I'm allowing every
buyer right now to decide without so I
don't have that problem in this model
that problem exists in the big picture
it doesn't exist in this problem yeah
okay so and so okay so the price was
fixed people bid they got allocated data
sets that determines the gain which
determines the price they pay that price
is taken and delivered to the sellers
okay that's there and then the market
updates the price and then this process
continues okay that's the real-time
market that we're proposing what are the
issues that come up all the issues that
you have in any type of market the first
thing is you want the individual buyers
to bid truthfully okay that is you want
them to build the value the way they
value the data and that means that
somehow this has to be structured forced
somehow by the the way the marketplace
is defined yeah that's interesting right
because then you're gaming the system
and gaming the system means that we
actually don't know how exactly to value
the data properly right but you know but
that's okay okay this is an assumption
yeah I mean it's good it's a
philosophical conversation but it has
second thing is you know how do you
allocate it what is your mechanism for
allocation and how are you define the
payment function okay it's interesting
you have a lot of choices
can you define the allocation and the
payment function in such a way that you
can guarantee the faithfulness okay and
then finally and also how do you divide
the division over here once you take the
payment and you want to divide it among
the data sets how you do
this in a fair way and I want to
describe what fair really means and
finally how do you update the price
vector to maximize the revenue at every
step all of these have to be defined
properly and also be computational in
real time for this market to actually
make sense okay so I'm getting to that
yeah so okay so the truthfulness quite a
quantity is yeah the truthfulness is
that when you actually when the buyer
basically the way they will bid they
would try to maximize their utility what
is the utility of the buyer is what they
get in terms of accuracy - what they pay
that the market defines I call that you
I'm not getting into the details of that
I want that maximization to equal to
their valuation that's what truthfulness
means okay well okay it's not obvious
how to do that it depends on a lot of
different factors the market essentially
what it does the market defines the
education and the payment and then we
want to define that in such a way that
you're not incentivized to game the
system so here is the first sort of
observation result well the assignment
of property of data to people is fairly
trivial you come in with a bid if your
bid is higher than the price of the good
you get the good okay and so this is the
allocation you get if your bid is
greater than P n of M which is the
current price that the market has for
feature M or data set then you get that
particular data set now that you got a
combination of data sets
what is your payment function and here
we propose to use meyerson's payment to
say that the payment is the incremental
gain you have for every feature you get
okay
that's the it's proposed before and so
what you're having is this is what you
get so G is the accuracy function that
you how you measure and M is some
algorithm that map's whatever allocated
said that you got so you have the
machine learning algorithm takes
allocated set of data measures how well
you've done the prediction and
and this is what you pay you what you
get - all the so what you get is the
incremental value so if you look at that
in terms of a graph like this what you
get in the meyerson's rule is the area
above in this graph over here okay
now the interesting thing it turns out
the the bid is is one number one number
that you you provide and then if the and
so that sorry okay so that number is
what you're willing to pay for one unit
of accuracy in your prediction you bid
that amount and what I want you to bid
is the truthful value it was a question
of the features that you're buying X X
sub J X sub J is one data set and you
advocate any one of these combinations
of this side of this data set right now
is only one buyer not I mean we're not
going to complicate this indefinitely I
mean it's already enough complications
in this simple model okay let me finish
and then I'll answer some questions okay
the price of the data is public we just
proved it there bit there there so
that's the point if this this payment
function is the correct payment function
then everybody is answer to incent
incentivize to bid exactly their truth
value it's what they perceive as the
value of the data to their their
function and they will be the exact
value
the maximum utility the maximum utility
for them of the bed equals their
valuation so it whether they know or not
this is the maximum attain this is how
much you get the maximum value out of
their let me let me keep going and I'm
coming to some of the properties that I
need for computation I'm coming to that
let me get there okay so okay so the
minus ins payment is the incremented
value the first statement is that if you
use this payment function then in fact
the education is is is equal to the
valuation which means that you're not
incentivized to game the system so
that's the first observation about this
particular question now the question is
now that payment has been collected you
bid your valuation the payment has been
collected how is it divided among the
different players and this is coming
back to the idea of how much value does
each dataset add to the precision of the
of the value of the prediction task
right so you get into this sort of
question of the shape education almost
like an allocation game right you have
to see forever if you allocated N and K
elements to this particular buyer what
is the value if take each one at a time
and each subset at a time and you get
this exponential growth and checking all
possible combinations okay so that's the
second thing is okay now what is
fairness mean first of all before I get
to the description of the algorithm the
first thing is that we want to make sure
that whatever you collected is divided
is given to to the sellers right so that
there is no percentage of that is taken
to them to the market now that one can
argue that maybe the market should be
paid in a certain way and we haven't put
that in there in the model second thing
is if two independent people provide
similar data sets with similar
contribution they need to be paid
more so if you have a dataset that
doesn't add value you should get zero
education and so forth this is that
notions of fairness and what happens is
that the Shapley allocation actually
guarantees the fairness there's not a
problem this is one known shape the
allocation will guarantee the shape
there the fairness
now the observation we made over here is
that actually the shape the allocation
as it's written it's written in terms of
an expectation over a uniform
distribution and so in general you don't
have to compute this application and
then exponentially you don't have to
look at all possibilities you can just
sample linearly on the set of
permutations and you will get
arbitrarily close to the allocation that
you want and you can actually write down
the concentration so you can get bounds
of how well you do if you take say a
uniform distribution over K steps okay
so that's another observation I think it
has to be although we didn't find it
anywhere I would imagine this probably
already existed in the literature so the
shape the allocation works it's fair but
it has one problem and the problem is
back to their application issue okay so
here's the situation that you have if
two sellers a and B provide the same
value for the prediction they actually
will get allocated equal amount of money
because they provided the same value
according to the shaky allocation so
then one of the firm's would say look
okay now I understand maybe I will come
in as a fake company with the same data
set okay and now I will get better
allocation because now the three of us
are allocated same value so I get one
third one third and so then and then
that means that I can get more profit
and that means that the gaming is
happening by the seller is not not by
the buyers that's maybe a question okay
and that's a hard problem and there is
posed to that problem that we have and I
think you know potentially reasonable is
that you have to now define some sort of
a distance between data sets okay and
penalize actually penalize data sets
that are close to each other okay so you
have some information distance between
there
and then what you do for the allocation
you actually penalize by the sum of
these distances okay that turns out to
be actually fairly efficient so what you
do you take the education that comes
from Shapley and then you scale it down
by the distance between different data
sets and then that lowers the allocation
but prevents the problem from happening
so quickly and pictorially what happens
when a and B are identical and you have
the scaling you get something like 1
over 2 e but then if you replicate it
now you get 1/3 a squared and that is
actually in some less what you would
have got earlier and you're not
incentivized to replicate there's a
problem with this though and the problem
is it doesn't have the balance the some
of these allocations does not equal to 1
because you scaled everything so now
either the market has to pocket the
difference which can happen a lot of
market ok all that we have to figure out
how to come up with a new scheme for
which you can also have balance and this
particular furnace well it turns out we
proved the following result that this is
impossible that you cannot actually do
the robustness and balance
simultaneously then in fact one has to
give in and there's a trade-off between
the two what's the right trade-off and
how can you get the maximum I would say
robustness minimizing minimizing the the
balance of the offset still an open
question we don't know how to answer
that question but we definitely know
that there is a trade-off because both
of them cannot be satisfied at the same
time another sort of kind of interesting
downside to these things is that now
even though a and B were not at
application of a the fact that they're
similar both are discounted so similar
data sets get discounted different data
sets don't get discounted as much okay
and so that means that the market
naturally is rewarding people that come
in with different data ok that could be
a problem in a sense that ok people are
sort of feeling that ok it wasn't my
fault that I'm similar to his data set
or her data set but at the same time the
market naturally wants to see new newer
ID
or newer data sets that can actually
imply or imply better accuracy and them
so this particular scheme actually kind
of you know discounts people that are
similar to each other okay
last piece is the revenue maximization
so now we've done all of this right the
market has computed the accuracy from
the accuracy if computed the price that
the buyers have to pay took the price
divided by the sellers and now the new
buyer is gonna come in when they come in
we have to update the price vector
update of the price vector is solving a
maximization or problem of revenue
revenue defined by the Morrisons
function those functions are complicated
and the price vector is a vector of
prices so there's a combinatorial effect
of trying to figure out how to increase
each one of these components so you can
either use multiplication algorithms
multiplicative algorithms or bandit
problems which we heard about before all
of them have pros and cons so to speak
right because the problems are really
complicated they're exponential and
complexity and what you start looking
for is additional structure that can
simplify this problem okay it turns out
there is actually interestingly enough
there in the myosins payment function
which is sort of what I described
earlier if you actually assume that the
gain function G of G not big G sorry is
submodular then actually get major
simplification so the reason this is
actually if G is sub modular and the
payment function has this form it looks
very much like lavash extension theorem
which tells you that if you can write a
function in terms of the difference of
submerged modular functions then that
function is convex I'm not giving you
all the details but that extension
theorem is actually very powerful so if
in fact G is submerged euler then the
resulting optimization problem can be
made convex now it's a little
complicated to guarantee that the
meyerson's payment is a submodular
function because it depends not only on
G G is fairly trivial it's like RMS or
or you know very same but it's the
allocation
and their algorithm that computes the
improvement that dictates whether you
have some modularity or not you can come
up with interesting examples and counter
examples of reasonable machine learning
algorithms that are sub modular not sub
modular so we're spending quite a bit of
time trying to understand how to model
this piece for the some of the examples
that I mentioned before namely the
retail example but if that is the case
then actually the problem becomes an
online convex optimization problem which
simplifies the algorithm tremendously so
quickly and I know I'm I'm out of time I
have a minute I wanted to say that what
we are doing right now is of course you
know we're trying to extend to the flip
side which I think brings up different
kind of Eva left the media that's sort
of the the flip side of it which is when
the buyers are are there altogether and
then there is externality to the buyers
and competition between the buyers so
that kind of brings in other
complexities to this particular market
and how to piece that together so we're
doing that but at the same time we're
building sort of prototypes for these
applications in particular one for the
retail and and and the other one for the
energy market these are markets that
will sit under the actual market I mean
there are markets on top of them right
and this will sit under those market
providing the correct prediction and the
product and the sort of the correct
supply chain necessary to run the top
market so trying to model the different
pieces of what would you take as a cost
function what would you take as a
machine learning algorithm what are the
prediction tasks that people who will
come up with now as you do this you
regulate sort of the way data is being
traded and value of prediction that
people are getting you begin to get some
structure for understanding for example
you know is are there certain ways in
which these bits behave or the
valuations behave and and we have some
ideas about how to do that as well all
right I spoke too much I stop here thank
you
[Applause]
but then the recommendation systems are
saying oh it's like the movie yes yeah
what is different about the movies a
little bit is that it's not clear by
buying a movie what prediction or what
sort of value I'm getting other than
entertainment it gets very complicated
trying to even understand my valuation
tries to appeal so the modeling piece of
my interest in the movie on how much I'm
willing to pay for is going to be
complex but it's interesting to think
about it that way why not I mean it's
the same thing pricing the movie should
also depend on these kinds of markets in
a way anytime there's a digital good
there should be a market that decides
how that how you pay the price for it
just said that the modeling becomes
harder it's a good question yeah I think
so I think so I don't have the answer I
think so it does look like you could
probably have market power data
companies probably can play that role
it's good to understand how much you can
actually impact the market by certain
types of data that you have or access to
data that you have yeah